en
foot bon soit vous êtes un homme
d'affaires libanais installé à kiev en
ukraine où vous possédez un groupe média
qui s'appelle super nova en 1998 vous
acheter la licence de la jasse de
mannequins élite pour d'abord pour
l'ukraine évidemment payer vous vivez
mais aussi pour la tunisie pour l'egypte
pour l'albanie et pour le maroc est
aujourd'hui vous affirmer qu au cours de
l'édition 99 du concours elite model
look en ukraine un des responsables de
l'agencé élite a exigé de tester une
jeune fille dans une limousine avant le
concours vous vous refusez vous envoyer
une prostituée une dénommée elena qui
d'ailleurs témoignera à londres dans le
procès qui est intenté par elite à la
bbc suite à un documentaire dont on a
beaucoup parlé ici est donc cette jeune
fille qui va témoigner et bien
n'a aucune protection
elle fini par modifier sa déposition et
elle finit par disparaître et
aujourd'hui on sait plus du tout où lé
voilà alors en résumé on pourrait dire
que certains patrons d'élite abuseraient
de leur position pour contraindre des
jeunes filles sélectionnées pour le
concours elite model look à se prêter à
des jeux sexuels vous allez vous
expliquer
oui
en fait un des dirigeants qui était le
patron du concours s'était pas n'importe
lequel c'était vraiment le chef avant
d'arriver la veille du concours il me
dit moi je vais maintenant arriver je
vais tester les filles je veux dire quoi
il m'a dit je vais faire l'amour je vais
coucher avec celle qui me plaît le plus
j'ai dit mais c'est pas possible me dis
mais c'est comme ça que ça se passe
partout c'est comme ça j'ai dit mais il
n'est pas question finalement il me dit
si tu le fais pas je te retire la
licence mois on pouvait pas me retirer
la licence c'était prévu de passer en
prime time à la télévision les sponsors
internationale et tout ça je fais une
réunion avec tous mes collaborateurs et
un de mes collaborateurs et mes dix mais
il ya des filles qui sont payés pour ça
et nous on peut lui dire qu'on va tu
organises et une fille alors je
l'appelle me dit non moi c'est les
mannequins qui me font bander comme le
terme qui m'a dit et j'ai dit bon alors
on annule je fais plus le spectacle il
me rappelle en me disant mais si elle
ressemble à un mannequin essayer les
blondes et si à la moindre de saison je
suis d'accord on lui trouve une fille
qui s'appelait lolita et puis il était
dans la limousine qui était la mienne
d'ailleurs j'en ai trois juments de plus
dans cette limousine après il a épargné
toutes les filles qu'il était satisfait
sexuellement il n'a pas touché aux
autres mannequins donc cette histoire
elle était pratiquement terminée je n'ai
pas parlé parce que moi je suis je ne
suis pas là pour balancer des histoires
comme ça mais si j'en ai parlé j'étais à
kiev personne ne va vouloir accepter il
fallait vraiment attendre le bon moment
pour le faire et je les fais quant à lui
simon demandé et en plus de ça j'ai
témoigné mois il ya eu cinq témoins avec
moi et cette fameuse lolita qui avait
signé sa promo son premier témoignage et
ont plus de ça ce fameux monsieur avait
fourni à la cour anglaise un document
médical qui prouvait qu'il était
impuissant sexuelle donc la cour
anglaise qui découvre que d'abord il un
faux document médical que non il est
loin d'être impuissant sexuelle et
koussa il était dans un peu dans
difficulté mais après deux semaines
après cette fameuse fille à l'appel elle
même la bbc elle dit je veux revenir sur
mes témoignages et ils ont refusé de
signer voilà de ses premières déprimés
on n'a plus de nouvelles d'elle
d'ailleurs la bbc il se sent un peu
coupable donc moi de mon tour je une
menace de mort à plusieurs reprises des
menaces au départ moi je prenais ce pas
ça au sérieux jusqu'au moment où je
reçois vraiment un message très
professionnelle et la bbc me disent bon
maintenant il faut arrêter il me met
deux gardes du corps britanniques de
lyme mi6 qui m'ont accompagné pendant un
mois et demi c'est à dire je devais
aller vivons au procès
l'agent il y en a un oui mais c'est
passé plus les britanniques ils ont
arrêté après la fin du procès ils l'ont
gardé pendant dix jours de plus donc
maintenant les britanniques ne protège
pas moi j'ai décidé de parler parce
qu'ils continuent à faire la pression on
vous dit que finalement le fait de
balancer parce qu'il faut dire quand
même que tout ça a commencé dans un
journal très sérieux quel journal
capitale ensuite on en a parlé dans le
journal le monde donc vous finalement
aujourd'hui vous dites que votre
meilleur défense c'est d'en parler je
n'ai pas le choix en plus haut point là
où je suis il faut pas que je revienne
en arrière il ya beaucoup de filles qui
attendent vraiment que ça se termine et
elle ose pas encore parlé parce que la
plupart des filles viennent des pays de
l'est elles ont des visas de travail qui
dépendent de l' agence de mannequins
donc en deux secondes leur visa est
annulée elles sont expulsées et en plus
de ça ou ils ont des photos d'elle avec
des gens importants et vraiment c'est un
réseau ultra grand gt1 rassuré quand
même des gens qui se sentent concernés
par ce que je dis important que je ne
veux pas aller balancer tout le monde ce
n'est pas mon rôle tout simplement je
veux que ça s'arrête si c'est possible
ou il faut faire une loi au parlement ou
autre il faut vraiment protéger ces
filles là et puis il faut que ces
dirigeants importants c'est ces gens
dans la police ou des chefs de presse
qui vont pas pour aider les gens des
litres est ce qu'ils ont peur de moi
mais plutôt changer de camp parce que
cette génération de ces choses-là doit
se terminer maintenant on est au 21ème
siècle il faut pas continuer comme ça
c'est grave ce que vous dites c'est
grave d'autant plus que depuis que j'ai
ri de l'article j'ai souvent des gens
qui me contrôler mes papiers à chaque
fois tu sors de chez moi en bas de chez
moi j'avais ras juste jeter un signal
d'éclosion qu'il fallait vraiment un
magazine capital et un journaliste
courageux parce que il ya eu plusieurs
tentatives de différents magazines et
journaux et d'autres journalistes pour
sortir cette affaire un capital il
travaille pas beaucoup avec évitant même
temps ouais ça doit être ça c'est un
magazine qui n'a pas eu peur des menaces
parce qu'à chaque fois que j'avais un
plateau télévision il essaie que de
l'annuler les articles ne sortait pas et
mêmes des grandes agences comme afp qui
les dépêches qui ont été annulés à la
dernière minute et tout ça donc il ya
vraiment des choses qui sont pas très
net dans tout ça c'est quelque chose à
ajouter non je voulais vous remercier
parce que c'est vraiment une occasion
importante pour faire connaître cette
histoire là mais c'est une émission
livrer la séquence s'appelle
expliquez-vous merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux